you guys it's Friday again time for
another movie retrospective there's a
good one here's another one of Jenny's
favorites now this one okay I debated
whether to do this one or not because
it's technically not a horror movie or a
sci-fi movie it's a comedy but it has
like Frankenstein II kind of horror
elements to it so I figured it was from
and the humor has aged well a lot of
heat a lot of humor and comedy doesn't
age that well it really does it Martin
most of his stuff aged pretty well even
the jerk aged okay yeah it's funny
because actually a listener sent this to
us and I was so excited because this is
one of those movies that you know as I'd
probably mentioned this on the show
before but when I was a kid growing up
you know we were kind of poor and but my
dad worked for Cablevision so we had all
the channels like right from when they
first came out because that was one of
the perks of this job was she got a
cable for free so you know pretty much
like from the second MTV started we had
MTV like so we hit and we had all the
pay channels for free and stuff like
that so a lot of my childhood was
renting movies at movie gallery slasher
movies or watching the same movie over
and over on HBO generation did that
watch HBO and Cinemax
yeah which is why I've seen time after
time as long as I'm the pirate movie
isn't as good on blu-ray cuz I saw it a
million times
I remember liking that movie I remember
being alright I don't know I was eight
since I was a kid I've seen in a long
time yeah and that's the thing about
this one the man with two brains this
came out of 1983 when I was 11 years old
and probably went to pay TV a year or
two later which is probably when I first
socks I didn't see it in the theater um
I felt like here's the thing I hadn't
seen it like I saw it so many times when
I was a kid I seriously had it memorized
and even when I rewatched it cuz like I
said one of our listeners sent it to us
and I was like really excited and I said
okay I'm gonna watch this again out it
will break my heart if it is not as
funny as I remember it being yeah yeah
why
I was excited I had one that I had
memorized you know the same way there's
history of the world part one I remember
that movie and I was and I thought
recently it wasn't funny the only movies
that I've seen from back then because
I'm not a huge fan of comedies I don't
see a lot of them you know I'm I'm
mostly a poor person so I do like some
comedies but it has to be a particular
type of comedy for me to think it's
funny guys I've kind of a weird sense of
humor
yeah the two movies that I've seen
rewatched recently that I loved as a kid
Ghostbusters still funny yeah I just
watched it like a man - they're okay
still funny yeah man what's your brains
still funny it's still funny I got to
hand it to Ghostbusters one though
that's still a solid damn movie it
really it is yeah it really is it has a
little bit of everything yeah I mean it
has humor it kind of has a little bit of
suspense even if you don't know what's
gonna happen it it's it does kind of get
a little spooky it's scary kind of has
like spiders yeah yeah yeah it's got
like scary parts yeah great soundtrack
kinda like Beverly Hills Cop one too
hard to beat those two those held up
really well - it was like actually I was
surprised I I saw those as a kid but
don't track either yeah but they didn't
make as much of an impression for some
reason like ghostbusters I saw in the
theater and like I loved that movie and
I was like I watched it again it was on
Netflix for a little while and I said
I'm gonna watch this again and see if
it's still funny and it's still funny
and this one like I said I saw it a
zillion times when I was a kid I mean me
and my brother used to like [ __ ]
quote lines to each other to this
officer you kook turn nines we used to
say all the time like [ __ ] like that so
I was like please let this still be
funny please still be funny because
obvious is that if it's not but it
really really still works and it's funny
because I looked at the Wikipedia page
for this briefly and there's really not
a lot of information there's like no
production information no no information
about like the writing of the script or
McCall's is in it yeah I'd forgotten
about this because yo let's check this
out okay so we washed again recently
right and there is a scene in it there's
a scene in it where Kathleen Turner is
getting
surgery and the the doctor decides
because it's Valentine's Day that he's
going to shave her pubes into a heart
shape even though she's getting brain
surgery and her pubes don't have
anything to do with it and Steve Martin
comes in and it's like what are you
doing to everything and that doctor that
did it or I guess he's a nurse is
Jeffrey comes because I forgot that he
was in it and then like when we washed
it again I'm like we should ditch every
couple it was a patroness sent us a copy
of this movie
yeah that's copy of a bunch of them and
I was like I love this yeah any movie
she wants to review just sent us a copy
or an original yeah yeah I mean we tried
to get around to all of them it's like
we have so many like I have this
humongous list like I said okay so the
whole thing the whole plot of the man
with two brains Carl Reiner actually
directed this so you know it's like
funny cuz he did like other funny movies
Steve Martin is the star of it he plays
a brain surgeon like a genius brain
surgeon named dr. haha so and he's the
funny thing about his character is that
I feel like Steve Martin was kind of
known for zany over-the-top humor but
the best parts of this movie are when he
coked out well that's not as much as
Robin Williams made not as much as Mel
Brooks Mel Brooks I don't think that
like crazy anybody's understand the EIP
for you youngsters you don't know the
eighties were so much a special time it
was cheap back then it was everywhere
yeah but like yeah that's the thing so
everybody was super coked up like oh
this my I wasn't cuz I was kids but you
know what I mean couldn't get our hands
on too young but yeah so but I think the
best parts of this movie are when Steve
Martin is just being kind of like
low-key because here's the thing like he
is a genius brain surgeon he has
invented this technique the cranial
screw top which basically you just
unscrew a person's head do this first of
it yeah it doesn't don't think about to
it and just pop the brain out and just
pop the new brain in you know whatever
you wanted to so so he's like this big
genius brain surgeon and he's like Ben
and although you know magazines and
everything like that but he's like super
super arrogant
but like the funny thing is when he's
like talking about how awesome he is
because he's very very low-key about it
you know what I mean because there's
this one thing where this guy's
interviewing him for a magazine and it's
like you know what did I say it's like
yeah my my contributions to science will
probably make me one of the most you
know amazing people like in history or
somebody's like take it the probably
though makes he doesn't wish you watch
it like so it's like that kind of [ __ ]
is the funniest now Steve Martin's
doctor afar he said i'm i hope i'm
saying yeah it's really funny so he is
probably much funnier than i'm baking
but so his wife has died and he was like
super super in love with her and he's
not really getting over it he had like a
Barbie doll made of her that like looks
like there was another funny part too
and he puts the Barbie doll up on the
thing and he's like is that her he's
like no that's not her that's a Barbie
doll before she gets into this to the
production quality on this movie is very
high I mean this is a good movie all
this ridiculous [ __ ] going on it is
really funny but honey ridiculous it's
filmed really well it's kind of like a
really good cast and just this just just
everything about it was if it's just a
good quality movie it's almost kind of
like watching it's it's it's as good as
ghostbusters one it's just a different
car I think it is yeah it's a different
like it's it's sort of in the same genre
because like the same genre it's kind of
like a horror tinged or sci-fi tinged
yeah comedy like it's got aspects of
Frankenstein in it
yeah but you know what I mean it's not
it's not as over the top of like this
batch it's a high quality movie very it
was a Hollywood blockbuster in its day
it was a high quality movie as good as
ghostbusters one yes I think is if you
like ghostbusters one see this one yeah
like look this one up yeah but yeah so
he's so like I said he's still getting
over the death of his wife and then
while he's like you know talking to this
guy that's interviewing him in the car
he hits Kathleen Turner he's playing a
woman named
Dolores Dolores is a horrible
gold-digging harpy and she has
contributed to the heart attack death of
her first husband just by being so
horrible and so like she gets hit by
Steve Martin's car and you know there's
this whole thing where he's like oh you
know the most preeminent brain surgeon
in the world you know hit her and is
able to save her life and it was like
this big thing and so he you know
understandably like falls in love with
her well she's in a coma but she is
still like I said a gold-digging harpy
so when she wakes up and finds out that
he's like this big preeminent surgeon
and he has all this money and stuff like
that she's this oh here's my next victim
so she kind of like pretends like to
fall in love with him she marries him
and all this other kind of stuff and
then and then it so happens that he has
to go to I think he goes to Vienna I
think it is and he meets this doctor
played by the wonderful wonderful David
Warner named doctor necessity and doctor
de sitter has apparently figured out how
to pop brains out of people and put them
well he wants to transplant brains into
another person but so far he's only done
gorillas and it hasn't worked out so
good yeah but he needs like subjects
okay so he gets subjects by this serial
killer that's running around Vienna
called the elevator killer yeah when you
find out who this I don't know if you're
the elevator killer yeah I'm not gonna
say how it is although it might not be
funny they wouldn't be funny to young
people know who the serial killer is the
serial killers Merv Griffin
okay playing himself yeah playing him
actually Murph great right that had the
timeshare are you younger people Merv
Griffin was a talk show host
very very very very hugely famous yeah
yeah and he was cool I remember him as a
little kid yeah this kind of like Johnny
Carson yeah like pretty much on that
same level like everybody knew who Merv
Griffin was he Merv Griffin though was
kind of intimidating he had a lot of
power to murder
could make or break you in Hollywood
Johnny Carson Carson yet Merv Griffin
was kind of more like a friendly guy
yeah yeah but there but he was he was a
heavy hitter in his day but the fact
that was back on a talk show where
people smoked and drank on the talk show
like we're always talking to here like
our show like we don't look anymore you
vape though a little bit but yeah so
that was kind of another joke - was that
the serial killer was Merv Griffin and
that and like I said it was actually
murder if it wasn't Merv Griffin playing
a serial killer he was actually the Merv
Griffin and his whole thing was the
reason why he was providing subjects for
doctor necessity was because he would
kill you by injecting essentially Windex
into your ass yeah and it would make
your brain die last so you would get the
bodies and like he could be be able to
probably not do it and it was still yeah
it's like I said it's a totally
ridiculous suit with some collar it's a
totally ridiculous Brian cross beam
Ghostbusters in Little Shop of Horrors
happen in this movie that's yeah that's
actually a good that's actually a good
thing so Steve Martin like while he's
dealing with this horrible wife that
he's married who he slowly begins to
discover like he's not really as bright
as he thinks he is so it takes him a
long time to kind of figure out what her
game is um but while he's at doctor
necessitous and he has all these brains
in jars and he figures out that he has a
psychic connection to one of the brains
and malmö hey and they it's actually
voiced by [ __ ] Spacek she is not
credited right but it's funny because I
recognize her voice immediately because
I've seen carey's million times yeah but
she's the voice of an in this so Steve
Martin falls in love with the brain and
then dr. necessity' tells him well the
brains don't last very long like in the
juice or in the you know liquid that he
hasn't preserved in she needs a body and
I'm not sure how well that's gonna work
out because I've just put them in
gorillas and it's not working out so
good
so he basically so Steve Martin
basically has to procure a body to put
this brain into that he has fallen in
love with and like I said I know it
sounds like a ridiculous price but I
think the cool thing the thing that I
liked about this movie because I'm not
super into I don't know I don't I don't
know if I want to say this categorically
but I'm not super in
zany kind of porn if it gets too zany
I'm just like knock it off I'm more a
fan of like more low-key or like
sarcastic humor like I like a lot of
British comedy and stuff like that but
this has its zani moments and the
premise is zany but the reason that the
it's played a lot of it is played
straight which idea makes it work
it's almost kind of like a 50s horror
movie something kind of like yes weird
brain transplant science fiction movies
yeah Lugosi or you know maybe like eyes
without a face type thing you know it's
gonna be it's essentially a horror movie
but it's funny yeah like everyone's
taking it very seriously yeah except a
great cast but they save funny [ __ ] you
know what I mean great casting they're
just Kathleen Turner down coke Kathleen
Turner coked out Hollywood people this
is so good I have to say this is like
what I was watching it again I'm like
wow this movie's like the only female
characters like a horrible horrible
Conte like SWAT this is funny though man
but she was so so funny and it's like
how often in a movie do you get to hear
Kathleen Turner call someone a [ __ ]
[ __ ] WAP never yeah but in this movie
she does oh yeah it was this movie was
intended to be just like violate it just
violated a lot of like like PC laws you
know I mean it was supposed to be
outrageous but the human humor was like
that back then
well the thing and this God like I said
this movie it's I saw it so many times
and it has so many great lines it's like
the but I love when he brings Kathleen
Turner home for the first time to use
like palatial estate and he's got like
two Hispanic or Mexican
you know gardeners or whatever they're
like saying the parts and she goes what
are those [ __ ] doing on the porch
he's like it's not [ __ ] pronounced
azalea's like all these [ __ ] flowers
so [ __ ] bored and obscure than one of
those guys and everything remember that
yeah that's the baby was like the pool
guy or one of the girls must like yeah
you tell me when that guy's gonna be
here alone
she's just a horrible character but you
can tell that she's like relishing it
like she's having so much fun like if
she was in that role kind of like a
stereotypical gold digger yeah you know
like he kept like a social climber like
he comes into the hotel room like in
Vienna and like there's like some old
Sigmund Freud looking [ __ ] like
like it with his hand like going toward
her butt and she's like he's paying me
ten thousand dollars to touch my behind
he keeps trying to screw her and she's
trying and she's just like she has a
headache trying to avoid that she wants
to screw the [ __ ] pool the pool guy
the Mexican pool guy doesn't have a pot
to piss in
yet his money tracking all his might
yeah that's basically her whole thing is
she just runs through all these
husband's because she's like super sexy
and everything so she can I get like
manipulate these men into giving her all
this money and that's what she's been
doing like I said they should her job
yeah so but then this you know this
whole thing happens where Steve Martin
falls in love with the brain and she
finds out about it because she actually
sees him like out on a rowboat he's
taken he's taken the brain out on a
rowboat on a date yeah and he puts wax
lips on it it's just the same old thing
where in the end he's trying to put the
perfect female brain into the perfect
female body the brain of a good girl
inside the [ __ ] body of a ho yeah
every man's dream really doesn't work
out quite the way he plans but it isn't
happy anything that brain in that body
that's the idea yeah that's kind of like
where the whole thing goes like I said
it doesn't end up exactly how he wanted
but it actually has a happy ending it
has like kind of a nice message at the
end of it but yeah so if you haven't
seen the man with you Brian seriously
1983 it's so so funny right so now I'm
gonna feel bad if like people watching
this go [ __ ] that's not funny it's I
think it's fun I think it's still fun I
think it's still funny after all this
time and I hope that's not just my
nostalgia talking zoom because I love
this movie I think some of the stuff
that some of the tropes and some of the
ideas and the concepts are kind of
universal
yeah it still kind of stands up and it's
yeah I think a yoga person would like it
like I said I think Merv Griffin being
the elevator killer is not it's not
gonna play the same as it did a 93
because that was universally known it's
kind of okay be like say David Letterman
is that yeah wait that's who's on now
Conan O'Brien oh yeah yeah was kind of
like that
I would hope young people still maybe I
was that was only a few years old but
yeah so other than that I think it would
pretty much play the same but like I
said if you like uh if you like Young
Frankenstein I can't imagine you not
liking this cuz this is kind of it's
like a similar I feel like this is a
similar vibe yeah to Young Frankenstein
type of thing not quite as much of an
homage to technically though and the way
it looked
it looks to me a lot like a cross
between Ghostbusters and Little Shop of
Horrors that's what yeah it is kind of
in that it's a comfortable car
comfortable it's a colorful kind of a
high-budget movie yeah had decent
special effects for what it was it
didn't have the special effects that you
find in ghostbusters
yeah what it didn't really have special
effects until the end didn't really need
them with the whole notion on par with
like the special effects you see in the
Little Shop of Horrors probably yeah it
didn't have the big talking plants or
anything but you know yeah is this
similar kind it was more like I said it
straight forward kind of it's a fun
movie story but yeah I thought it was a
lot of fun so thank you for sending that
to us because I love that movie so much
that was one my favorite movies growing
up and I was so excited to see that it
was just as funny as it was when I was a
kid and like I said me and my brother
used to [ __ ] we used to quote this to
each other all the sentient dramatist
rain and was it reanimate er yeah well
yeah he sent us a whole bunch of
different yes we watched them all I
think yeah he's got two shows yeah we
always appreciate it and oh and he sent
last man on earth
yeah
they've been surprising it's like yeah
we always appreciate free movies if
anybody wants to send them we have seen
that one yes I see well I saw it I saw
it again that's black and white right
mm-hmm yeah yeah we wish I feel like
it's you know yes I am psycho Mega Man
or I am Legend yeah it's based on I am
Legend by Richard Matheson honestly I
think that's the most faithful
adaptation all the other ones kind of
went in their own direction Omega man
though what Nevel his Air Force jumpsuit
with his Colonel Santa's MK 760 Smith &
Wesson submachine gun mowing down the
dam as long as somebody has a cool gun
and/or a cool motorcycle or car yeah the
world may be the king of Los Angeles
there was nobody left he was the last
man you would love that [ __ ] with you
well he went crazy remember he's playing
chess with himself well who else are you
gonna play actually he's playing chess
against Caesar yeah you had a bust of
[ __ ] with the hat on it with his hat
on okay so what else are you gonna do
there's nobody else around yeah and even
if you did find somebody else they
probably don't know how to play chess ya
know so what else you gonna do it's a
good flip though I don't think I would
go crazy we gotta do one on the Omega
Man yeah we probably should wait did we
already I don't think we did Omega Man
did we we've done so many that yeah well
I'm pretty sure we did a baby we did I
think we did Omega Man look at serious
earner he's like wait do we think I
don't make ads money because we had like
one of our listeners was like oh you
should do the thing I was like dude I
think that's the first we did it we did
the thing we did like a whole but we
didn't really we did I know I said well
sometimes I have to go back and check
because I was like well cuz I have the
list and it's like sometimes I have
movies on the list and then we never get
around to those some movies I'd like to
redo again because the sound quality was
so bad back then I went back trying to
listen to my Conan review and man I
could barely hear it really yeah yeah
well now we have a good megaphone you
might have to take some of the old ones
down redo them I have to redo them
although I'm an actual listen to them so
I can remember what the [ __ ] I said cuz
that
do it over let's see we don't scrape the
[ __ ] yeah we don't scare obviously but
yeah like I said if you like sort of
horror tinged comedies and you haven't
seen it cuz like I said it feel like it
kind of if you didn't have pay TV back
then you might not have even heard of it
or seen it cuz weren't alive back then
that's all the Wikipedia pages like I
went look to it cuz I was like Carl
Reiner directed that right now went and
checked and then I was like what the
[ __ ] there's like hardly anything on it
it's like a plot synopsis and that's it
and a cast list that's all gone there
and they said it would have 76% at
Rotten Tomatoes so you know 76% of
people have good taste there you go so
anyway that'll do it for our latest
movie retrospective remember if you like
the show like share subscribe and all
your social media if you'd like to
financially support the show you can go
to our patreon page patreon.com/lenguin
there's a link in the sidebar to a
PayPal account if you'd like to make a
one-time donation it'd be much
appreciated also remember our movie
retrospective is just like this one come
out every Friday our 13 o'clock matinee
show which is three new movies in the
theater that comes out every Sunday and
our regular episodes which are usually
true crime or paranormal [ __ ] whatever
we feel like doing they come out every
Tuesday so check them out and we will
see you next time bye